[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'll how are you guys doing today
y'all I'm really glad to be here
so this talk is about civic hacking j/s
pretty much helping your compute
community with JavaScript or how as
exposed and eventually use javascript
and learned a lot of things about
different frameworks doing Saavik civic
hacking throughout texas but first how
am I really what do you know about me so
I graduated from Notre Dame with a
degree in environmental science and from
there I was an environmental scientist
and oil and gas got laid off and I've
had to come to like Jesus moment and I
was like what am I good at
and I was like coding and fencing so I
actually end up becoming a fencing coach
at a new brand new club and I saw was
there in-house developer and I
freelanced for three years while trying
to find my full-time gig in back in
Houston along the way every six months I
would do something very drastic to try
to get a tech job and one of the things
I ended up doing was like becoming a
tech organizer a little bit but another
thing I did before I decide speaking was
a thing was actually got involved in
civic hacking so but now I'm an
associate scientist and training at
crimson Vista doing cybersecurity so in
Baltimore so I just started back in like
April so it's really brand-new thank you
[Applause]
so what is civic hacking really this is
a definition that open gov dated IO
gives but really civic hacking is just
about people they're fed up about how
slow government is moving but look
Kapiti has needs today and just a group
of people are just very very angry at
government slow processes and they're
just like let's get done today
instead of like for like nope like
February 2002 but who are Civic hackers
other than these people being angry
Civic hackers can be anyone in the
community actually can be you it could
be you and the man in the mirror but you
know that is a Michael Jackson joke and
I'm kind of off topic because this is
supposed to be a prince - a prince talk
but pretty much any one day has like any
needs and any technical skill can join
it's inclusive but really what did I get
involved in this
I like there's me in the mayor and my
prince pajamas somehow that happened but
like really I'm a nice person and I like
doing good things so that was like
number one nostril checklist but really
the big problem was I had hackathon
burnout so pretty much I was doing all
these hackathons and building apps that
would never see the light of day after
that like weekend it would just end up
going into the graveyard of github where
you know all the other to do apps
[Music]
but I actually was thinking to myself
instead of building like a fun app that
will never see the light of day what if
I had spent that at time building an app
that would actually help somebody and
like make a difference in somebody's
life so I wanted my work to be a little
bit more meaningful so open data is
great I don't know about you but how
many of you guys have like done web
scraping for fun I saw hands go up and
and down at one point I like but I don't
know like web scraping like a government
web site is kind of different because
I'm opposed to be like a wet hacker and
I don't want to find out the hard way
that orange isn't my color so open data
is great and all but what if we actually
built apps to be open source I know
there's a lot of frameworks that are
open source that gives us tools but
already the big problem is cities across
the nation that have similar problems it
would be great instead of like starting
out from scratch you can just go to
somebody else's repo and see what they
did and they would be like hey take our
work and like improve it to your own
circumstances right another thing is
what I found out is civic hacking
communities are diverse naturally so
pretty much back in Houston the scene
over there pretty much as the
demographics of Houston so but in other
communities like Austin you have other
like there was an asterisks to this
because like in Austin there's problems
there there's jeremy gerrymandering
and also you know other things that have
been going on to push out certain
demographics and you see that when you
actually go to those meetings because
like no one is going to drive 50 miles
just to do civic hacking
except me but that's another thing so I
end up going to the I drove down to
Austin with a friend so and I went down
to do a hackathon yet again I couldn't
escape them and did the hack for Change
and pretty much why I found there was a
project to using reacts so budget party
was that was a app built on reactor to
help people understand the budget and
get voters excited about what's going on
with the budget and why should we and
why should we like be concerned and
actually look at it so I was really
excited to get in there so another thing
about civic hacking is JavaScript has
like a wide pithre ax of different
frameworks and tools and you could just
decide to use anything you want and no
one's gonna judge you for it so and you
get to play with different tools that
you haven't get to play with or play
with tools that you would play with at
work but you're afraid to like mess
around with them at work because they're
gonna shut everything down and make
everything implode and get fired so I
ended up learning about react at the
time cuz I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't
angular one person at the time so I just
wanted to like learn about react and I
was able to because due to membership so
one of the things that our community
sometimes stumbles on is mentorship
outside jobs because like I know our
industry really wants people there like
senior roles but like they came from
somewhere people don't sprout out and
become like senior developers what eight
years experience wouldn't react out of
nowhere I liked how like the dev opening
said you know but what I really liked
about this was someone took the time out
to help me understand react
and it became like a cycle so when I
ended up going back home I was teaching
my other friends react and other
framework so it was just like a good
like circle of life kind of thing
another thing I found out at this RIT
hackathon was developers really do not
like WordPress so at the time what was
going on was there was this one project
that was using WordPress and there were
all designers and they wanted a feature
built and there was out of like 100
developers no one would come and help
them and I felt sad for them and being a
nice person I went to help them and when
I figured out was they had no
documentation on what the person before
did so I wasn't really able to help them
but I rendered I figured out how
important documentation was that day but
at this point I realized I was missing
my keys my friend had my keys and I was
freaking out because I didn't want to
walk all the way back from Houston to
Austin like from Austin you know Seattle
and Portland is the same distance
between Austin and Houston's for some of
you guys still don't realize how big you
mean Texas is in general so I went over
to his room and figure out why hasn't he
given back my keys so I found out that
his team was having a breakdown
they were pretty much siloed off into
their roles and weren't communicating
with each other it was pretty late on to
like the hackathon it was like pretty
much like 6 p.m. at the first day and
for hackathon terms if you don't have
anything by then that's pretty bad sign
so I decided to help them out
I earned up building something for them
like I end up like do only a little like
site map for them and just a little
sketch to know that what they can plan
on
and I wasn't really planning on doing
this but I I didn't really plan on doing
this but like they just needed direction
and to get something done but I wasn't
really expecting like what my work was
like have a name and actually have a
role define to it so but because like at
that time I was just a freelancer mining
my own business just getting websites
built but I didn't know that there was a
whole section of our industry actually
made for people to tell these people
what to do so it was really important to
like think about your co-workers that
you have back home that their work is as
significant as well so and civic hacking
is pretty much about seeing a need and
then filling that need no matter what
your role is at work pretty much so I
went back to my little react group for
budget party and I don't know about you
guys but bugs are like cockroaches like
I don't know if you seen the cockroaches
back in Texas but they fly and it's
pretty similar to like at work like and
when you see one of these roaches
somebody is screaming it's usually a
manager and they don't screw able to
stop screaming until like the bug is
fixed and squash so like I took my
experience with like fixing like
squashing cockroaches to fixing bugs and
react and I actually ended up building a
little bit more confidence like instead
of being afraid of roaches and bugs I
was like hey I can actually do this and
it just built up my confidence which
each one that I smushed it smashed along
so unfortunately I was the only person
in my group that was based in Houston so
how did it go back home but I continued
being part of their program
and helped out so but it was lonely so
we actually had successfully that app
end up going on to win the Mozilla
Internet health prize and one of my
friends from the group going to England
so I came back to Houston and then we
had our own City hackathon pretty much a
day before the hackathon we found that
Houston had a pot of money just for
housing that wasn't going to use it
wasn't being used and pretty much that
there was this rebranding of section 8
housing being called housing choice and
pretty much we came up with a plan like
about 16 to 20 of us actually came out
with a plan for homelessness in the
vacant housing problem because of the
oil and gas like slump and we try to
figure it out we can build an app for
this and
and we did we used HTML and CSS and of
course JavaScript you know JavaScript at
us hugs you know the parent you know
whatever but because that's pretty much
what everyone knew we didn't know there
wasn't a collective of people knowing
just one framework and we didn't want
anyone to be left behind so we kept it
vanilla we ended up building this super
like elevation of an app trying to do
several things and we didn't win the
hackathon but the mayor called a society
it's like hey you're doing something
about this keep on doing this I give you
permission to bug people they're
actually going to use this app so we
rented up back to the drawing board and
we actually wanted to like go ahead and
interview these people so we could
actually build an app that would suit
their needs so we had a new plan in
place our group considerably shrink down
to five people and I was like I have a
game plan I'm gonna build this out and
react as I learned it and then I'm gonna
use WordPress API to actually bring in
the data from the old databases of
government and then I'm gonna use meteor
AGS in the background and I moved on
right thinking this is going to be done
it's gonna be great but then this this
happened I found out very quickly like
nine out of ten times government
officials will not meet with you they
are very very busy people in this hands
it was caseworkers they were overloaded
and kind of had to bribe them what lunch
Shh but to make them actually show up
but they did once or twice but it wasn't
enough to actually flesh out this app
because we wanted this to be an app for
them and we found out like Houston is
big y'all we end up driving like 30 to
40 miles into town each time and that
actually is a substantial gas bill after
you do it a couple of times so we
decided we're going to find a way to
sponsor ourselves and we're like let's
do grant money but that also is a long
process that first you had to find the
right grant for you
and then you have to wait until they
decide and read all the proposals and
then you might not even get it but this
was fine
we thought we could wait but it got to
the point that we just if you don't have
like we had all the energy but if the
world doesn't want to work for your
change right now there's nothing you can
do to push it along so and we found out
housing like insurance is a very thick
hard thing to improve but this was fun
because this happened so this is my
neighborhood so pretty much you had the
palace in picture so what had happened
was Palestine was like the original
flooding from Harvey and then you have
the armed guard over there saying hey
you have to evacuate because we're going
to release the dam and then they
released a dam up on top so so all this
took over a week period so but I was
already in the slack group for our civic
hacking groups get City so we all
congregated there and then people from
outside of Houston also integrated in
there giving us like slack had to give
us free tier at the time and pretty much
we are in a building out like around
like 2030 good apps like the big one
being Harvey
and then we had like other ones for SMS
attacks using Twitter and Twitter gave
us free tier thank God
also muck rack and just a lot of like
Maps and shelter and just telling people
like where to go to get goods and needs
they might not hence the title Harvey
needs and I know that we don't really
think about this much but like a little
speck machines matter so when we're
working in these groups like some of
these people are working from like their
teams at work and they have like various
ways they build things like things that
actually you have to go and use things
that you have to use sources like
applications that actually use like 16
Giga RAM to get in so all you get to you
get to the point that you start up and
you're only able to clone the repo and
then you're not able to do anything else
and then you're not actually able to
like go to localhost which is really not
exciting so it's really heartbreaking as
a developer for someone to tell you that
your machine is a parity a barrier to
entry but what's really heartbreaking is
that you end up building like a desktop
app and no one can use this desktop app
because your users don't have desktops
they only have phones and no one can go
to the library because your library is
flooded so no one can use your desktop
app so I know so setting up development
environments can be a lengthy process
like we have so many like spin-ups
and CIS so this helped us like develop
quicker oh I don't know do people
actually like playing with wet pack and
starting things up I'm like cuz that
could take that could take a couple of
hours honestly so we end up things using
things like CRA CMS is like WordPress
even though people don't like WordPress
they saw like they needed to get things
up quickly so they they used it
another thing we found out really easily
it was pair programming was very useful
especially when you lost your laptop in
the flood and you still wanted to code
so you know so you got to like hang out
with your friend and use their laptop
and also still be able to contribute
right but then also coding blind is very
hard especially when you're trying to
like some people are just like putting
in HTML tags and like turn in and over
slack and just like they're not part of
the you can't stand up their own
development repo so they're trying to
contribute but you can't really see what
like as front-end people you can't
really see what's going on and you just
have to like hope that your code makes
it look right and have the faith that
somebody else will correct your mistakes
and talking about mistakes it's okay to
fail in this circumstances because
you're not getting paid for the work
you're doing so and your job is not on
the line it's just millions of others
but like they weren't gonna get anything
done in the first place so so it's like
it's a safe place to fail so no one's
gonna blame you they're gonna be like
damn I really wish during this hurricane
this developer got this thing right I'm
like no it's more like hey I hate you
mother nature my home is gone but it
wasn't just only coding so we pretty
much had a environmental crisis our
hands so like my background and the
viral science helped out especially when
it came to like water quality and then
finding out that everything was
contaminated so but then again hurricane
armor happened and we really weren't
expecting that to happen like really
like for like oh this is almost gone we
can go back to normal but then this
happened and pretty much we ended up
going to a different flat group and in
that slack group
it was pretty much the armored response
group so pretty much the people from
Houston we migrated over to that slack
group and we were like hey here's all
the apps we built all you need to do is
change the branding and like the URL and
here you go right so we helped with
homelink we didn't build the same thing
twice but there were some innovations
that happened on like from they learned
from our mistakes they had the chat box
so pretty much a tat box was an easy way
for people that were fleeing their homes
to like actually use their phones and
get in touch with simple messages to
like guide them on the right path
so however unlike the team back in
Houston that all knew each other
the Florida team was people that really
didn't hang out together so they didn't
really know each other and they were all
in different cities and they didn't have
like one big central like big city that
all of them met each other so they
didn't really know each other and it was
just like a circle of like trust not
being there so let's do a little trust
exercise so how many people can trust a
person that's sitting next to them their
code raise your hand I saw hands go up
and down what is this it's like wavering
make a choice okay now all the people
that still have their hands up put your
hands down if the person that is next to
you as a co-worker put your hand down if
the person next to you is the Twitter
celebrity
okay so it was only like like this group
over here like what's your story ah so
they had a community where they actually
learned from each other similar to civic
hacking and thus why they trust each
other despite working long hours at work
or seeing Twitter feeds of different
code geniuses things they've done in the
past so and also there was different
sources of data but you know people
couldn't really trust that source of
data because it ain't trust that person
causing like a cachet of like an
infinite loop they couldn't get out of
of data trust so but then Hurricane
Maria happened and that was different
because assembly using a slack group we
are and abusing whatsapp and what
whatsapp you know there's a limit of how
many people can be on that group so we
actually end up losing people and we
didn't run we're in contact with some
people and we didn't hear from them
during and some of them we didn't hear
from them after so it was a scary time
we were prepared to do the same things
but it was a little bit different from
like some of my group of friends we
ended up doing a create negative that
and we actually thought it was a great
idea because people would actually use
their phones first and it just didn't
work out because like FEMA was like no
like no not on my watch and I just had
to find out there's some things that the
government should actually pay attention
to and actually just they should be in
charge of that and they should do that
but it shouldn't always solved they
shouldn't always fall down to
individuals because there's only so much
we can do but the good thing is through
this getting to know people in person
and joining an open like source
community the civic hacking is pretty
much the most open source that you can
but on the fly I was able to get back to
open source and
the rat community and also participate
in a friendly what is it called a
holiday party where the reacting that
pitcher is react versus angular and I
was on the react team and we gently like
one against angular by one point so but
it brings me back so like meaningful
work I'm like I don't know about you but
there's like different apps like
everyone's working on different things
at it like work but like some things are
more crucial than others and then some
people are just working on is hot dogs
so but there's a way like if you're
working on is hot dog that is fine you
have to make your money somehow but you
can just if you want to get involved you
can get involved like doing things small
and local you don't have to go far you
don't have to drive around a whole state
plan a you can just join your local
brigade like every city has a brigade
the brigades I went to were open Austin
and the my local brigade would sketch
city and you can find your brigade right
here like there's a website for that so
if you want to get involved but if if
you don't have time or if there isn't a
brigade you can start your own honestly
but there's always Plan B you can
convince your workplace and usually if
you're like working in a good place your
workplace will be like yeah we'll go for
it but if you're working for a like a
more you know where you work for though
really like I don't have to like tell
you like to put yourself out there if
it's a place that you know they're not
going to go for this but you know that's
my little shady thing you know if you
work for evil calm so pretty much this
has been a tale of pretty much my
hacking experience Pacific was safe
akaky in 2017 I'm glad you guys stayed
frigid journey and these are things I
learned the hard way not the easy way so
and this is it thank you guys
you